back to back against mr. fantozzi yeah
and I'm not going to give him the point
again on the silver plate like last game
after you got outplayed I was blundering
the house I can let's try to avoid that
in this game yeah but that shouldn't be
possible let's see if I had to set aside
in an earlier game was it be should be
five I cannot remember the AIDS or just
93 hand should be 50 rupee 826 there was
some problem with this I cannot remember
and anyway address going back it's not
enough compensation anyway this is not
this there's a line that is quite
similar but it is not exactly this line
okay so this should be too I guess
okay so what is what is it what what is
your plan yeah you just want to take it
back and be worse right okay so let's
see I can take you five here give him
give him the rook in the corner it's
definitely playable chinks chinks why
it's a bit fancy but still probably good
let's do it I really want to punish the
sky the the last game was a bit
frustrating
Queen a one has 97 okay he wants to
check wants to get killed it seems and I
really hope that this happens that looks
very fishy so I can check him here and
let's see check on c6 any other checks
Bishop g4 is also pretty interesting
check and also looks winning should be 3
and also looks good you have it yes this
should really be enough
where are you going with your king so
check on d3 check
okay efore check is one possibility but
i'm not sure about my next move is after
that 26 actually looks very good let's
do that before maybe well then I have
push up a three if I really don't see
anything better and I am Bishop e3 is
good though and there's also evil check
okay here there's also a for check but
yeah let's do it Jeff if one check
you know H forms winning a five winning
Bishop takes two fighters Whitney I
think I play Bishop takes you 5 i'm just
taking this laddie queen before I'm
miscalculating some nonsense it's
probably there's also probably some made
but after the last game and that's it
let's just keep it simple check check
check check
check
check yeah he loves the game of chess
even check with the Queen down he's
happily continuing
black resigns yeah I had simply don't
believe in the opening but I'm not
completely sure how this compares to
that other line the gambit lining with
the Queen on c7 I had to exactly the
same stuff in an in a game just like two
weeks ago and I couldn't drill him I
forgot again how it's done 9595 because
here i can't take and this is not enough
compensation yeah okay so this is
probably strong txt group b aid this is
what the engine gives hmm it still
doesn't feel one hundred percent clear
for a human player my development is not
non-existent rights to pawn store 92 and
stop which is very optimistic okay okay
i just i just went back yeah i was
thinking he plays like a bishop d6 in
this position but he surprised me with
this okay I'm just of course happy to
give stuff back but this is probably not
going to work Bishop detours is the
simple move but I wanted to be fancy and
the engine agrees very nice that is the
strongest move the point is that if he's
not grabbing if he does that I go bishop
in three and this is a disaster with the
king in the middle so TX TX and now ok
King takes us losing straight away this
is more interesting i was thinking 25
the engine gives queen a form okay here
queen e 5 is kind of high even that is
good with bishop a 3 to come
at kuehne a force stronger I'm not sure
that would have done that I probably
would have played Queen takes d5 yeah
here widest was winning according to the
computer quite amazing and this this for
example is winning check with this and
these ideas interesting i didn't see
that fight was just based on intuition
and he had so it's over right yeah
completely over check check get Queen d6
as a strong smooth yeah okay I'm across
that wasn't bad 25 and check and this is
this is a clearest curious way just take
the Queen and think later have there's
some kind of checkmate I really wanted
the winner after the last game after a
gifted him that so on keep it to keep it
simple this is a good method okay well
thanks for watching